once one of the funniest men in
Hollywood these days Vince Vaughn
struggles to find laughs on the big
screen what got the star swingers and
wedding crashers stuck in a career run
flops Vaughn's Hollywood dry spell may
have to do with the fact that his last
few movies have tanked with dismal
reviews 2016 unfinished business about
three co-workers who embarked on a
European business trip gone terribly
wrong made headlines for its shockingly
low box office returns according to box
office mojo the film grossed just four
point seven million dollars in its
opening weekend to become the worst
performing major release of Vaughn's
career the fact that it finished its
theatrical run with about ten point two
million dollars against a thirty five
million dollar budget only looked worse
unfinished business followed for other
flops the internship the watch the
dilemma and delivery man and only
delivery man managed to earn a profit on
its domestic box-office and only because
it was so cheap to make in the first
place ouch true defective when Vaughn
agreed to star in HBO's second season of
True detective he may have been aware
that his career was in a rut the show's
critically acclaimed first season was a
highlight for Matthew McConaughey's in
2013 if it worked for him it could work
for Vaughn right of course we now know
that true detective season two couldn't
live up to its predecessor and Vaughn's
performance didn't help much whether he
was threatening characters or reciting
one of the series notorious monologues
he looked out of place and out of his
depth by the end of the season it mainly
served to remind us that Vaughn is only
fun to watch when the laughs are
intentional casting confusion for years
after wedding crashers Vaughn struggled
to find his footing in Hollywood often
choosing roles that felt very out of
place there was the awkward attempt of
becoming a romantic leading man like in
2006 the break-up
two years later Vaughn starred opposite
Reese Witherspoon in four Christmases in
both cases Vaughn's style of humor
didn't match the rest of the movies fans
longed to see him in the dude friendly
movies that made him popular what they
got was couples retreat and Fred Claus
oh ho no getting older when your career
is defined by frat boy movies like
swingers old school and wedding crashers
eventually you get too old to play those
parts now in his 40s Vaughn has
officially entered that territory the
only time that he should be on a college
campus is to take one of his kids on the
tour speaking of family man another
reason he may not be a top dog in
Hollywood anymore
Vaughn's actually been married to
Canadian realtor Kyla Webber for several
years they have two children together
daughter Lachlan and son Vernon it's
possible that Vaughn has slowed his pace
to focus on being a husband and a dad
after over 30 years in the business he
may be tired of the grind plus with a
reported net worth of fifty million
dollars he's not in danger of being
unable to provide for his family and
maybe fatherhood will inspire his new
direction the right Pixar project may be
all it takes for a family-friendly
version of Vince Vaughn to mount the
brilliant comeback we're all waiting for
it seems to be working for Owen Wilson
thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know how you think
Vince Vaughn can start swinging again